y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa soy santiago lópez gonzález este
es el espacio de france 24 en el que
hacemos un resumen de las noticias más
destacadas relacionadas con la pandemia
del comit 19 a continuación algunos de
los temas que vamos a tratar en esta
edición
vamos a tener en vivo al doctor carlos
eduardo pérez infectólogo y asesor
científico de france 24 para conversar
sobre diferentes temas el pico de
contagio que está viviendo la región
latinoamericana la controversia frente a
las vacunas producidas por astrazéneca y
por johnson y johnson y también los
satisfactorios resultados que ha tenido
la vacuna china sinovac en chile también
vamos a ver cómo está la crítica
situación en brasil los casos están
aumentando allí sin parar los fallecidos
también la red hospitalaria está al
borde del colapso y algunos medicamentos
y sedantes ya comenzaron a escasear
hasta los cementerios están trabajando
24 horas para enterrar a las víctimas
para lado ms brasil comienza a hacer una
preocupación para la seguridad sanitaria
internacional y conversaremos con cindy
regidor la corresponsal de france 24 en
costa rica quien nos contará cómo está
avanzando la vacunación en ese país y en
la región de centroamérica también
hablaremos del nuevo pico de contagio
como está golpeando intensamente a costa
rica y de nuevo los hospitales allí
están comenzando a mostrar síntomas de
saturación mientras que el gobierno
evalúa
a imponer o no nuevas restricciones a
los ciudadanos comenzamos pues ya los
decía que vamos a comenzar primero por
los anuncios que hubo a lo largo de esta
semana hubo anuncios importantes por
ejemplo el de la ope ese que afirma que
sudamérica es la región más preocupante
en cuanto al aumento de casos de kobe 19
este organismo explicó que casi todos
los países suramericanos principalmente
han incrementado los contagios y que la
mitad de las muertes ocurridas en el
mundo durante la última semana tuvieron
lugar en esta región brasil colombia
argentina perú y méxico están entre los
20 países más afectados con el número de
contagios más altos a nivel mundial
asimismo denunciaron que américa latina
y el caribe no están accediendo de
manera equitativa a las vacunas de las
210 millones de dosis que han sido
inoculadas en todo el continente
americano más de 155 millones han sido
aplicadas solamente en eeuu que es el
país que lidera en la vacunación a nivel
internacional
pues hoy es día de consulta y de aclarar
dudas con el doctora pérez epidemiólogo
de la universidad nacional de colombia y
ustedes ya lo conocen asesor científico
de france 24 está con nosotros aquí para
aclarar y responder algunas preguntas
doctor pérez como siempre es un gusto
tenerlo aquí en el programa y quiero
comenzar por el dramático aumento de los
contagios y los fallecidos que hemos
presenciado a lo largo de esta semana en
la región de américa latina' otro pico
porque están avanzando estos picos y
estamos en un avanzado proceso de
vacunación qué significa este tercer
pico y
creíamos que conocíamos este virus pero
tal parece que el virus logra volver a
imponerse y nos vuelve a llevar a estos
picos
santiago buenas noches uno de los
problemas es la aparición de este linaje
en brasil que definitivamente tiene un
comportamiento de ser mucho más
contagioso más pegajoso podríamos
decirlo así y además de eso produce una
infección más severa eso hace que los
casos líquidos se impliquen con
facilidad sea porque el contacto cercano
hace mucho más fácil que este virus
digamos se reproduzca en la comunidad y
además de eso que en esta época de
semana santa o un relajamiento de
nuestras medidas de confinamiento se y
una activación social de reencuentros
familiares y definitivamente hoy estamos
viendo las consecuencias de eso
definitivamente la vacunación no sigue
siendo alta sigue siendo muy baja
excepto chile las tasas de vacunación
son bajas somos susceptibles
no tenemos comportamiento social y
tenemos un virus mucho más pegajoso
mucho más contagioso y más agresivo
entonces todos estos detonantes hacen
que en la lógica de la pandemia
aparezcan estos picos doctor pérez
también fue destacado esta semana ese
pronunciamiento por parte de la
a la administración de alimentos y
medicamentos de eeuu que sugirió a las
autoridades sanitarias de este país
norteamericano que no utilizaran la
vacuna de astrazéneca hasta que no
investigarán en profundidad qué es lo
que sucedía con los trombos también
sucede lo mismo con la vacuna de johnson
y johnson que ha generado ya todo tipo
de controversias a nivel internacional
veamos el siguiente reportaje para
entender esta situación qué es lo que
está pasando con estas vacunas y ya
volvemos con el doctor pérez para seguir
comentando al respecto
un nuevo revés para los intentos por
frenar la pandemia este martes la fd y
el cdc de estados unidos recomendaron
suspender el uso de las dosis
desarrolladas por el laboratorio janssen
filial de la multinacional johnson and
johnson tras registrar casos de
coagulación sanguínea
hoy la fda y el cdc emitimos una
declaración sobre la vacuna del cuvi 19
de johnson and johnson recomendamos una
pausa en el uso de esta vacuna por
precaución de los 68 millones de
personas que han recibido las dosis de
janssen en eeuu fueron 6 mujeres menores
de 50 años las que registraron coágulos
graves y extraños una de ellas han
muerto y otra está en estado grave no
obstante la fed ha remarcado que la
gente no debe tener miedo ya que los
beneficios de la vacuna son mucho
mayores a los riesgos desde la casa
blanca han asegurado que este percance
no afectará la vacunación nacional ni al
objetivo de joe biden de aplicar 200
millones de dosis en sus primeros 100
días
por precaución la fda y el cdc han
recomendado una pausa en la vacuna de
johnson and johnson tenemos suministros
más que suficientes de facer y modernas
para continuar con el ritmo actual de
vacunación de 3 millones de inyecciones
diarias tras la noticia la compañía ha
decidido retrasar la distribución de
dosis en europa allí la emea empezó a
investigar las el viernes bajo sospechas
de coagulación aunque ha remarcado que
no hay ninguna relación clara entre la
vacuna y los casos de trombos la vacuna
de janssen es de las pocas que se
aplican una sola dosis por lo que es
vista como un arma para frenar la
pandemia sobre todo en los países con
menos recursos para neutralizar el cob y
19 usa un virus conocido como adenovirus
y tiene una eficacia del 66 9% su
suspensión temporal podría afectar al
ritmo de vacunación mundial
doctor pérez la fe y la cdc hacían
énfasis en que han sido seis casos
registrados con personas que han tenido
trombos particularmente estos seis casos
han sido mujeres menores de 50 años qué
sucede con esta vacuna con esta vacuna
de johnson y johnson esta situación no
se presenta ni con la sinovac ni con las
putt nicb y como extensión de esta
pregunta américa latina debería seguir
el ejemplo de eeuu y algunos países de
europa que han restringido el uso de la
vacuna de astrazéneca ahora la de
johnson y johnson incluso por ejemplo
dinamarca ya dijo que no va a usar la
vacuna de astrazéneca
definitivamente ante esta evidencia hay
que tomar algunas precauciones algunos
países europeos por ejemplo recomendaron
no vacunar a personas a mujeres oa
personas jóvenes menores de 30 años como
si son reino unido y seguramente se
hacen algún ajuste y algunas
recomendaciones porque lo que hemos
visto y tanto en la con astrazéneca como
en jansen comparte que son las mujeres y
generalmente menores de 55 años este
tipo de casos probablemente las
recomendaciones serán para ello pero el
beneficio de las vacunas sigue siendo
muchísimo más alto que este riesgo otros
medicamentos como los anticonceptivos
orales y otros medicamentos que usamos
en la práctica diaria tienen incluso más
riesgo que esto de la vacunación pero la
gente sigue tomando con anticonceptivos
y se toman precauciones pero no se
elimina esa posibilidad es necesario que
haya vacunas que tengamos mayor oferta
mayor plataformas de vacunas seguramente
tendrán restricciones para el uso de
algunas y es segmentación en grupos
poblacionales
y eso sería como el comentario acerca de
estas vacunas doctor pérez hablemos del
tema de brasil la situación allí es
crítica lado ms ha alertado a la
comunidad internacional sobre lo que
está sucediendo allí algunos analistas
han calificado a brasil como un
fukushima sanitario porque están todas
las condiciones generadas para que haya
un gran desastre sanitario debido a que
el virus está allí circulando libremente
ya tiene una variante propia que tanto
deberíamos los países de latinoamérica
que somos los más cercanos a brasil
preocuparnos por la situación que se
está viviendo allí
es una preocupación inmensa
y anunciada los científicos brasileros
los infectólogos los neumólogos y toda
la ciencia advertida desde hace varios
meses que la falta de concentración y
armonía entre la política los
ministerios y el gobierno y los
gobiernos locales e iba a suceder esta
catástrofe tenemos varias situaciones un
virus circulante mucho más agresivo un
virus que afecta a las personas jóvenes
incluso sin comorbilidades una gran
densidad poblacional unos un servicio
sanitario frágil que está al borde del
colapso y eso hace que haya mayor
interacción mayor circulación viral
probablemente esa mutación se genere y
se expanda en los países vecinos y en el
mundo como ha sucedido con la variante
del reino unido con la variante de suero
africana probablemente esta que se ha
documentado ya en algunos países se
pueda volver la flora predominante y por
eso es la carrera es la vacunación de
nosotros y sobre todo en brasil en el
control de foco debe ser prioridad del
mundo sino si logramos que brasil
controle su enfermedad
sería un problema menos para la región y
por eso tenemos que unir esfuerzos pero
realmente es una situación que nos
preocupa no solamente la región sino el
mundo y a la ciencia nos tiene la
monitoría todo a cada hora acerca del
comportamiento del virus en brásil
si ya hemos visto que los países que
tienen frontera con brasil no han
hablado entre ellos para tomar una
decisión en conjunto sobre qué hacer
precisamente con las poblaciones
fronterizas con la situación con brasil
que tiene prácticamente fronteras con
casi todos los países de la región menos
con ecuador hablemos ahora de chile
porque esta semana las autoridades
sanitarias de este país presentaron un
informe después de haber analizado la
vacuna sinovac que es la que han estado
utilizando allí desde hace varios meses
y hablan de un buen desempeño de esta
vacuna entre los chilenos ya llevan casi
siete millones de personas inoculadas
por lo menos con la primera dosis que
más se sabe sobre este reporte
es un reporte bastante alentador porque
aquí ya es un estudio de efectividad y
no los estudios de eficiencia que hemos
hablado durante estos meses
recordemos que el estudio de eficiencia
son en un campo ideal en un estudio
clínico y los estudios de efectividad es
en el mundo real lo que nos muestran los
científicos chilenos es que vacunar
evita el 67 por ciento del codis
sintomático el 83 por ciento de la
hospitalización un dato muy muy
importante que es evitar el 89 por
ciento de ingreso han vencido y evita un
80 por ciento la mortalidad la
vacunación
estos datos se siguen alimentando y
pronto serán publicados estos son estar
informaciones preliminares para poder
validarlo pero ciertamente los estudios
de efectividad fueron mejores que los
estudios de eficacia y muestran datos
muy positivos sobre todo para el código
grave para el código de cuidado
intensivo que es lo que colapsa los
sistemas de salud es una buena señal nos
recordemos que el 93% de la población de
chile es vacunada con sinovac
ha demostrado estos estudios de
efectividad que son alentadores para los
países que seguimos usando esta vacuna y
que es de las que tenemos disponibles en
la región y es una de las vacunas más
ampliamente usada en la región de
américa latina no está autorizada para
ser usada en eeuu y en europa por el
momento doctor pérez muchas gracias por
estar con nosotros aquí en hobby 19 la
semana en américa como siempre un gusto
aclarar todas estas dudas y que usted
nos explique en palabras simples estas
situaciones que les hemos traído en la
consulta muchas gracias vamos ahora
actualizar a algunas de las cifras de
casos en la región para este cierre de
semana según el conteo de la universidad
johns hopkins eeuu sigue a la cabeza a
nivel mundial y continental también con
más de 31 millones 500 mil casos
confirmados brasil tiene más de 13
millones 700 mil casos mientras que
argentina supera ya los 2 millones 629
mil casos colombia está muy cerca
también de argentina con dos millones
seiscientos 2000 y méxico cierra esta
semana con dos millones 295 mil personas
confirmadas con kobe 19
el municipio de serrana en el interior
del estado de sao paulo en brasil fue
parte de un experimento médico que
arrojará enormes aportes a la lucha
contra la pandemia en tiempo récord esta
ciudad fue aislada y la totalidad de los
habitantes fueron inmunizados contra el
kobe 19 para determinar el
comportamiento del virus también de la
vacuna y de una aparente inmunidad de
rebaño france24 estuvo allí y ahí les
contamos qué fue lo que encontramos
en serrana el coronavirus tiene los días
contados y no solo por la labor de
desinfección que el equipo municipal
realiza desde hace un año
hace un mes las escuelas se han
convertido en centros de vacunación el
instituto butantán lleva a cabo un
experimento científico sin precedentes
vacunar a 28 mil voluntarios es decir el
97 por ciento de la población adulta
significa significa mucho fue muy bueno
que haya acontecido porque vamos a
quedar inmunizados nos vamos a librar de
esta enfermedad libres
rara es una ciudad dormitorio y sus
habitantes circulan en toda la región
para trabajar desde el inicio de la
pandemia registró un porcentaje muy alto
de contagios por eso fue escogida para
el estudio nos vamos prevenidos somos
privilegiados y agradecemos mucho este
proyecto que nos está ayudando en este
momento en este momento este es el
cuartel general del instituto butantán
en serrana desde esta sala un equipo de
médicos e infectólogos coordina una
investigación pionera
serrana fue subdividida en 25 pequeñas
áreas estamos analizando la cobertura
inmunológica de cada una de estas áreas
para determinar si eso tiene relación
con la inmunidad de rebaño y con la
reducción de casos graves y
hospitalización a dos internación este
estudio también intenta determinar cuán
eficaz es la vacuna contra las
mutaciones del coronavirus el alcalde de
serrana se muestra muy optimista
hoy en el municipio ya tenemos en torno
de un 55 por ciento de disminución de
los casos graves creemos que es un
resultado bastante importante si tenemos
en cuenta que todavía no acabamos el
segundo ciclo de vacunación son los
resultados pueden influir en la lucha
contra el cob y en brasil y en todo el
mundo israel que ha sido un ejemplo en
la vacunación ha mostrado interés por
ese estudio mientras los habitantes de
serranas siguen cumpliendo la cuarentena
obligatoria en el estado de sao paulo la
situación crítica en san pablo ha
llevado a las autoridades locales a
permitir los entierros nocturnos para
dar capacidad
a demanda de los servicios funerarios
sao paulo es la ciudad más poblada de
brasil con más de 12 millones de
habitantes y es asimismo también la más
afectada por la pandemia contabilizan
más de 2.7 millones de casos 25.000
fallecidos mientras que el estado de san
pablo contabiliza ya más de 86 mil
fallecidos el colapso sanitario está
nuevamente a la vuelta de la esquina
la ciudad de san paolo se ha convertido
en el epicentro mundial de la muerte y
la formosa es el cementerio más grande
de américa latina
los entierros se suceden sin parar es un
ir y venir de su cultura eros y féretros
esta familia acaba de enterrar a su
abuela se la debe entrada del hospital
ella fue ingresada con algunos problemas
de salud y en el hospital fue
diagnosticada también con kobe esta
mañana tuve un paro cardíaco y no
resistió a una parada cardiaca
la presión sobre el sistema funerario es
tanta que ha sido necesario transformar
los autobuses escolares en carros
fúnebres
al atardecer una empresa especializada
enciende los ojos para que los
enterradores puedan seguir trabajando la
sepultura son realizadas con rapidez
no hay una área reservada a los
fallecidos por covers pero constatamos
que son la mayoría
este albañil perdió a su cuñado el
entierro nocturno no fue su elección ha
sido una propuesta del ayuntamiento hay
muchos sepelios y ellos han prolongado
el horario nos ha tocado a las 21 horas
este fue el horario en que nos dejaron
venir
y el aumento descontrolado de las
muertes preocupa el sector de los
sepultureros
en un año el número de entierros en san
paolo se ha duplicado y el trabajo
también este líder sindical explica que
hay que sumar constantemente los cuerpos
para ganar espacio en el cementerio de
prefectura amplios serbios desde hace
muchos años exigimos que el ayuntamiento
amplíe el servicio en sao paulo
construir cementerios verticales y mas
crematorios si las muertes continúan
aumentando a este ritmo sin duda
podremos llegar a ver un colapso del
sistema funerario de hoy de un juego
absoluto serbios vulnerarse gestionar
tantas muertes supone un alto coste
físico y emocional este sindicalista
denuncia la falta de apoyo psicológico y
la escasa protección de los empleados
subcontratados es crítica a la situación
allí vamos a conectar con valeria
saccone la corresponsal de france 24 en
brasil para conocer más detalles hola
valeria ya lo decía yo la situación es
crítica en el país y está a punto de
convertirse en una emergencia sanitaria
a nivel mundial la situación es muy
complicada valeria ya no hay ni siquiera
sedantes para los pacientes que tienen
que ser entubado
las peores previsiones se han cumplido y
abril ya es el mes más mortal desde el
inicio de la pandemia pero dónde es
realmente dramática la situación es en
muchos hospitales el río de janeiro los
médicos del hospital albert schweitzer
han denunciado que en muchos pacientes
se despiertan durante la entubación por
la falta de los medicamentos analgésicos
y sedantes en algunos casos están
teniendo que atar estos pacientes a las
camas para evitar que intenten quitarse
los tubos de la garganta y que se hagan
daño la situación venía siendo
denunciada desde hace semanas y hemos
llegado a este punto los médicos dicen
que absolutamente inhumano intubar a los
pacientes sin los medicamentos adecuados
están utilizando medicamentos
alternativos que no son tan eficaces y
al mismo tiempo tienen más efectos
colaterales es una situación conocida
por el gobierno de hecho hemos sabido
que el año pasado en agosto el gobierno
de jair bolsonaro paró la compra de
medicamentos sedantes para incubación
sin dar ninguna explicación
la realidad hoy es que están faltando y
que los precios en el mercado se han
disparado esta semana el gobierno
prometió que va a distribuir 2,3
millones de medicamentos a partir de hoy
ya lo hizo al final de marzo y no
cumplió con su promesa
mientras tanto empresas privadas e
incluso gobiernos extranjeros como el de
españa han anunciado que van a donar
esos medicamentos a brasil
valeria la cifra de personas que
fallecen en brasil está superando a las
cifras de personas que nacen la cifra de
nacimientos y también está comenzando a
repuntar la cifra de recién nacidos que
fallecen en todos los estados brasileños
qué es lo que está pasando allí
esta semana hemos conocido otro dato
preocupante por primera vez en al menos
12 ciudades de brasil el número de
muertes por coronavirus supera el número
de nacimientos es el caso de río de
janeiro donde hay alrededor de 36 mil
muertes y tan solo 32 mil nacimientos o
de porto alegre donde hubo 3 mil 221
muertes frente a mil 509 nacimientos
además preocupa y mucho la muerte lavada
de bebés por corona virus o de las
autoridades sanitarias calculan que son
1300 y se preguntan los especialistas el
porqué algunos lo achacan simplemente a
la pandemia descontrolada que ya no
conoce edad en brásil
de hecho en la franja de edad entre 29 y
49 años la mortalidad ha aumentado hasta
un 400%
valeria en este momento es donde uno se
pregunta dónde está el gobierno federal
brasileño qué van a hacer las
autoridades porque ya no hay ya no hay
espacio para ser preventivos pero toca
ser reactivos la situación se está
saliendo de control allí
es cierto la organización mundial de la
salud ha pedido al gobierno de gerardo
sonar en más de una ocasión más acción
para hacer frente a la pandemia yo diría
que las situaciones casi de parálisis el
gobierno va a remolque lo vemos con el
caso de la compra de vacunas se
perdieron meses preciosos en los que no
se hizo nada para asegurarse los stocks
importantes para vacunar a la población
y ahora el ministerio de sanidad anuncia
cada dos por tres nuevos acuerdos pero
con empresas que sólo van a poder
entregar en el segundo semestre de este
año además a jair bolsonaro lo hemos
contado varias veces hay bocas
boicoteado en varias ocasiones a los
gobernadores se opone a las medidas de
cuarentena e incluso recientemente hizo
una denuncia ante la corte suprema para
intentar suspender la especie de
lockdown que algunas algunos estados
habían introducido el supremo le dio la
razón a los gobernadores en estos casos
se creó también tarde y mal
una comisión de enfrentamiento a la
pandemia que reúna los varios poderes
pero de momento
la comisión vacía de contenidos que no
ha ofrecido grandes resultados y también
se ha aprobado la creación de una
comisión parlamentaria para investigar
la gestión del gobierno de la pandemia
de nuevo ha sido una imposición del
supremo se ha aprobado su creación pero
todo va muy lento y no se sabe todavía
cuándo van a empezar a trabajar
y mientras tanto los muertos pasan por
el frente del gobierno federal brasileño
valeri hablemos de esa experiencia suya
grabando los reportajes que vimos
previamente allí en el estado de san
pablo usted estuvo en diferentes
hospitales y también estuvo en el
cementerio más grande de américa latina'
cuéntenos esta experiencia
la semana pasada junto con mi colega
louis hole pasamos varias horas en el
cementerio de san paolo vila formosa que
es el más grande de américa latina y
debo de decir que durante todo el tiempo
que estuvimos allí los sepultureros no
pararon era una verdadera cadena de
montaje de la muerte y tengo que decir
que cuando estamos grabando los
periodistas como los cirujanos le
ponemos digamos una cierta frialdad a
una cierta distancia a la situación para
poder hacer nuestro trabajo sin embargo
editando el reportaje tanto yo como
louis nos dimos cuenta de la
dramaticidad de la situación es un no
parar y por eso que ni siquiera hay
fecha para acabar con los entierros
nocturnos que el ayuntamiento de san
paolo ha introducido para aliviar un
poco la carga de trabajo en los
representantes de los sepultureros nos
contaban que además hay un trabajo extra
se pasan el día desenterrando viejas
esculturas para hacer más espacios
denuncian que no se hizo inversión en
este cementerio para hacer nichos
verticales y debo de decir que la ciudad
es muy triste impacta de verdad nosotras
desde el inicio de la pandemia hemos
estado en entierros en hospitales
grabando intubados digamos que se espera
que un reportero se acostumbre pero la
magnitud de esta tragedia es tan grande
que nos ha dejado toda la semana muy
tristes es muy triste y muy difícil la
situación allí en valeria gracias por
este reporte valeri por compartir con
nosotros estas impresiones de este
difícil trabajo que usted realizó allí
en uno de los cementerios de san pablo a
continuación pasó a presentarles las
cifras del avance de la vacunación algo
positivo en medio de esta situación para
el continente americano para el cierre
de esta semana estas son las cifras del
número de personas que han recibido al
menos una dosis de alguna de las vacunas
que está disponible en el mercado en
norteamérica ya van 146 millones 146
punto 14 millones de dosis inoculadas
mientras que en suramérica 42.54
millones de dosis inoculadas por países
veamos eeuu
a puesto 125 como 82 millones de dosis
aplicadas a brasil en el top brasil
tiene allí 24.80 10 millones de dosis
sigue méxico con 9 millones de dosis
supera a los 7 millones de dosis que ha
inoculado el chile y cierra este top
uruguay con 996 mil dosis ya aplicadas
por lo menos a buena parte de la
población
y vamos a conocer cómo está la situación
en costa rica y el resto de
centroamérica allí también hace frente a
la nueva ola de contagio y también
algunos países como costa rica y como
panamá están avanzando rápidamente en la
vacunación sin de regidor desde san jose
nos va a dar mucha más información o las
indy gracias por estar con nosotros en
el programa y cómo está avanzando
particularmente en costa rica el avance
de la vacunación en ese plan nacional y
luego en la región
[Música]
sí mientras algunos sectores de la
población reclaman que la campaña de
vacunación no avanza tan rápido como se
necesita la comisión nacional de
vacunación y epidemiología explica que
hace lo necesario y tiene la limitación
de depender de las entregas que hacen
las empresas a las que se han comprado
las dosis de vacunas se han tomado
algunas medidas como por ejemplo reducir
la reserva para avanzar más rápido en la
colocación de las vacunas sobre todo
porque ya hay una tercera ola de
contagios en el país costa rica- alcanza
una tasa de vacunación de 11.37 por cada
100 habitantes en el primer grupo
prioritario conformado por más de
100.000 personas de la primera línea de
respuesta contra la pandemia ya más del
70% tiene las dos dosis aplicadas y en
cuanto al segundo grupo compuesto por
unas 850.000 personas mayores de 58 años
sólo el 18 por ciento tiene el esquema
de vacunación completo
si de allí el sistema hospitalario en
costa rica ha logrado hacer frente a
esta crisis sanitaria a lo largo y ancho
de todo el territorio costarricense pero
algunos conocedores del sistema y
especialistas allí en éste país dicen
que alrededor de finales de mayo de
junio el sistema podría estar saturado
debido a la cantidad de pacientes que se
están presentando allí que dicen
desde mediados de marzo hay un
incremento de casos y en las últimas
semanas volvieron a incrementarse
también las hospitalizaciones la caja
costarricense del seguro social tuvo que
habilitar 640 camas para pacientes kobe
en menos de 15 días se duplicaron los
internamientos y en los últimos días la
ocupación de ussía ha alcanzado el 90
por ciento los expertos señalan con
preocupación que el aumento de
hospitalizaciones por coronavirus afecta
también la atención hospitalaria de la
población con otras necesidades médicas
por distintas patologías el ministerio
de salud también dijo que ese
crecimiento de casos se da en medio de
un escenario más complicado por la
circulación de la variante que se
originó en brasil la de sudáfrica y la
de reino unido el ministro dijo también
que es posible doblar la curva pero para
ello se necesita afrontar la situación
con responsabilidad dijo que está a
favor de retomar actividades y apostar
por la recuperación económica pero no a
costa de más casos más internamientos y
más fallecidos
cindy para terminar este panorama de
costa rica- qué medidas preventivas se
mantienen allí y cuáles se está
estudiando el gobierno tal vez volver a
imponer a los ciudadanos para evitar un
aumento crítico de los casos de contagio
costa rica nunca ha tenido severas
medidas de confinamiento pero si hubo
cierre de bares restaurantes
instauración de teletrabajo en el sector
público suspensión de clases
presenciales cierre de fronteras y un
sistema de restricción vehicular poco a
poco estas medidas se fueron eliminando
o flexibilizando con el inicio de esta
tercera ola las autoridades dijeron que
no tomarían nuevas medidas ni cierres
pero justo recién anunciaron que la
restricción vehicular para los fines de
semana volverá a estar vigente es un
sistema sencillo en que los carros de
placas que terminen en dígitos pares
sólo circulan los sábados y los de
placas con último dígito impar sólo
pueden hacerlo los domingos esta medida
genera molestias entre algunas personas
pero las autoridades han insistido en
que la restricción vehicular tiene un
impacto importante y comprobado
estadísticamente en la movilización de
personas y en los contagios
cindy desde allí desde san jose hagamos
un repaso por la región por
centroamérica nicaragua ha tomado pocas
medidas para evitar los contagios el
salvador ha hecho un intenso trabajo
para poder vacunar a la población en
panamá y costa rica son los que lideran
allí y nicaragua digamos que junto con
guatemala han recibido unas cuantas
dosis y avanzan lentamente en su plan de
vacunación que más detalles hay
si costa rica y panamá llevan la
delantera en centroamérica con números
bastante parecidos panamá ha vacunado a
529 mil personas para un ritmo de 13 por
cada 100 personas y costa rica lleva a
586.000 para una taza de 12 por cada 100
personas el salvador ocuparía el tercer
lugar con una taza de 56 y después
quedan guatemala y honduras con 0,9 y
0,6 respectivamente
nicaragua es un caso particular porque
la información que brindan las
autoridades es escueta la organización
panamericana de la salud dijo que no
tiene datos específicos sobre el avance
de la vacunación en ese país pero
recientemente el ministerio de salud
dijo que avanzó un 35 por ciento en una
meta que contempla vacunar a pacientes
cardiópatas oncológicos y personas
mayores de 60 años aproximadamente unas
60.000 personas habrían recibido al
menos una dosis de la vacuna en
nicaragua los países centroamericanos
dependen del ritmo de las entregas de
las casas farmacéuticas y en buena parte
también del mecanismo kóvacs de la opc
que busca garantizar vacunas para el 20%
de la población de los países
muchas gracias indie por este completo
reporte de la región centroamericana
sinti regidor nuestra corresponsal en la
ciudad de san josé en costa rica
a continuación veamos otras noticias
destacadas durante esta semana en
nuestra sección en redes aquí en kobe 19
la semana en américa y vamos a comenzar
en panamá este país recibió el décimo
lote de vacunas con 77 mil 200 dosis
este lote llegó al aeropuerto
internacional de tocumen en ciudad de
panamá y este país ya ha recibido 600
7230 dosis en total hasta el momento
desde el pasado 20 de enero con este
lote se dará prioridad a la segunda fase
de vacunación para las personas mayores
de 60 años y también vienen las primeras
dosis para docentes y para embarazadas
que comprenden cerca de 40.000 personas
cambiamos de título veamos vacuna de
sinovac que evita 80 de 100 muertes por
kobe 19 según un estudio de acuerdo con
los resultados de un estudio realizado
en chile
hablábamos hace unos minutos con el
doctor pérez sobre este informe que
presentaron resultados de la efectividad
de la vacuna china
dos meses de inmunización masiva ya
cerca de 10.5 millones de personas han
recibido una o dos dosis los resultados
indican que tuvo un 67 por ciento de
efectividad en la prevención de
contagios sintomáticos por kobe 1990 y
6.5 por ciento de efectividad a la hora
de prevenir hospitalizaciones 99.6 por
ciento de efectividad para evitar que
las personas ingresen a una unidad de
cuidado intensivo y 99% de efectividad
para prevenir la muerte
y para terminar esta noticia en japón no
descartan cancelar los juegos olímpicos
y empeora la pandemia el secretario
general del partido gobernante de japón
indicó que la cancelación de estos
juegos olímpicos previstos para el
próximo verano boreal es una de las
opciones sobre la mesa en caso de que la
situación en ese país asiático siga
empeorando por lo que le pidió
colaboración a los ciudadanos japoneses
para evitar un aumento considerable de
los contagios de kobe 19
y así llegamos al final de kobe 19 la
semana en américa nos vemos la próxima
semana con más información de nuestro
continente del continente americano
sigan cuidando el kobe 19 sigue estando
presente en la emergencia continúa y la
única forma es usando tapabocas y
alcohol en sus manos hasta pronto
[Música]